good morning John hey today's inspired
by a comment on John's video about me
needing to be punished I'm going to talk
about the science of pain while
experiencing pain what start out with
pain that's detected by the systems that
are designed to detect pain this is
called nociceptors pain the kind of pain
that we need something bad is happening
and so our brain is like this is
unpleasant run away there are three
different kinds of nociceptive pain
first a superficial somatic nociceptive
pain this is basically skin based pain
we have tons of pain receptors in our
skin because it's our first line of
defense so we need to gather a lot of
information when I get whipped my skin
can feel every single lash of the whip
as a separate pain deep somatic pain on
the other hands what we feel in our
muscles they're burning or when we have
a strain or a sprain or a broken bone
it's a less specific pain but it could
be extremely intense this is a weird
kind of pain test right now my muscles
are undergoing anaerobic glycolysis
which is increasing the acidity of my
muscles neurons are detecting that
increase in is it being relaying that
signal to my brain as pain and Wow
wow that's painful I don't canna
nociceptive pain is visceral pain this
is usually pretty vague and distant but
can also be very intense for women think
of cramps for guys think of testicular
injuries I'm not gonna demonstrate this
it would be dangerous I'm an addition
and dose receptive pain the other kind
of common pain is neuropathic pain when
your nerves are damaged or malfunction
and send pain signals when they
shouldn't one of the only big nerves
that runs close to the surface of the
skin is right here your ulnar nerve and
if you whack oh oh I did it
I achieved gold complex funny bone
that's that's your neuropathic pain I
didn't think I was gonna do it so good
referred pain on the other hand is when
the source of the pain gets mixed up by
your nervous system yes there's a
stimulus but no it is not being received
in the right place oh well my eyes were
watering oh good thank God it was
recording I thought I wasn't recording
for a second oh wow you're nociceptive
pain system can also be tricked and
other stand this we come out to
understand how the entire nervous system
ward cells the detect sensation whether
that's pain or light or smell this kind
of work the same way they spend almost
all their time maintaining an ion
gradient across the membrane of the cell
so there's a different charge inside the
cell than outside also on the surface of
the cells have these channels that when
open to equalize that ion gradient so
they become neutral at the surface of
those channels there's a protein that's
designed to open the channel when a
specific thing happens that circumstance
can be the presence of some or heat or
sound or light this is how we detect
everything all of our sensations
sometimes circumstances that these
surface proteins weren't designed to
respond to nevertheless activate for
example there is a protein called t PR
v1 that's designed to open a channel in
response to heat acidity or abrasion but
it also just by chance opens in the
presence of a molecule called capsaicin
capsaicin is entirely harmless it just
no damage to your skin but it does open
that channel so it is detected by your
brain as pain and capsaicin is the
chemical that makes Chili Peppers hot
all the burning that I'm experiencing
right now has nothing to do with actual
damage inside of my mouth it is purely a
biological accident and all my body did
not believe it no pain is an important
system we live inside of our bodies we
would be nothing without them so we have
to protect them people who are born
without the ability to sense pain often
die before adulthood but it's not like a
super well designed system or anything
it's extremely old it's a holdover from
ages and ages of evolution ago it leaves
a lot of opportunities for things to go
wrong and so many people have to deal
with chronic pain that is extremely
difficult to manage but for most of us
though in elegant and unpleasant pain is
oddly enough something we should be
thankful for John I'll see you on
Tuesday today is inspired by a comment
on John's video about me needing to be
punished I'm going to talk about a
little don't need to be Bonello about
meeting oh my god it has the first
sentence of the video this time so he's
my friend Anna
[Music]